ينضم الينا عازف القانون جهاد اسعد جهادي
يسعد صباحكم نورت صباح العربيه اهلا بك
انت من اشهر عازفي القانون في الوطن
العربي لو تحدثنا اولا عن هذه الاله
وتاريخها صباح الخير اول شيء لكم لكل
المشاهدين
قله القانون تاريخها منه كثير معلوم بس في
اساطير او رومانس بتنحكي عن موضوع يحكى
انه الفرابي هو اللي اخترعه حوالي 1000
سنه من الف سنه ويقال انه اول ما اخترعها
ما عمل فيا الفتحات بالخشب فشلت الاله معه
وضبه بمحل وبعدين مع مر التاريخ لان الخشب
وبعدين اكتشف انه المفروض يفتح فتحات فيها
من هون طلع ال- همم
فيما بعد تطور هو العرب رجعوا تطوروا
اتراك زي دول العرب
طيب جهاد قد ما صوت القانون جميل جدا وحلو
هو يسمى ايضا قانون لانه دستور الالات
الموسيقيه قد ما هو عمليا صعب حمله من
مكان الى اخر وانك تاخده كرفيق دربك مثل
جيتار مثلا او الطبله يعني مع اختلاف
العزف اليوم تحويل فكره القانون الى مشروع
قانون متحرك ماذا
تعنيته والتعلم عليها بس مش هون الموضوع
المشكله انه دايما ااه العازف كان يبقى في
مسافه بينه وبين جمهور او بيني وبين
المستمع لانه هو دائما جالس بمحل معين عم
يعزف ما قادر يتحرك انا اخترعت بالالف
2012 حديد بتتركب مثل الستان
تنحط بينحط قانون عليا بصير الشخص قادر
يعزف هو عم يمشي
يعني بتكون معلقه مثل الاكستنشن منه لانه
هي اصلا الايه
هذا الكانسر بموريال الشهر الماضي
سوو بنحط الالوان وبيقدر الشخص يقدر هو عم
يعزف يتقرب من جمهوره اكثر وهو يحس حاله
ويحس القانون بارت منه مش انه قاعد طيب
حبيبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معلش انا لحبيبي وحبيبي الي على كل حال
راح نكسب كمان نسمع كمان مره جهاد مشاركتك
مع فنانين كبار في مسارح في برامج
تلفزيونيه لو تحدثنا اكثر عنها
انا بلشت موسيقى بعمر صغير
[موسيقى]
انه
شاركت مع الفنان العرب محمد عبده
همم واكتر غير وطبعا ان احنا بالعالم
العربي مشهورين
بالبروجرامات للمواهب بروجرامات
التليفزيون فكان لي الحظ كمان همم شارك
همم دي ذا فويس على الام بي سي وشارك كبير
بعراق ايضا وغيره من بروجرامات واكيد كل
شيء تسجيلات ستوديو ريكوردنز يعني الاغاني
اللي بتسمعوها مسجل فيها القانون بشارك
فيهم وخصوصا من بعد كرونه صار فينا نسجل
ريموت لي هو واحد فيكم ساكن وين مكان او
عم ينطلق على
شو ما كان ويكون معه
يكون معه
ويسجل
وشهر الماضي كان عندنا كبير مع عازف همم
وبالمانيا
[موسيقى]
معكم ميلودي اجنبيه بس لتشوفه انه القانون
قد ايه بيقدر يكون فيرس ستايل وفيه كذا
ستايل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني بلا تشاو بينفح شرقيه
احجام للقانون
اللي انا بعزف عليه
تركيا تركيا
وشفت انونو صغير عند سامي
طلبت منه يعمل لي
قانون بعد اصغر من هايدا في اصغر يعني
بيكونوا ثلاثه ثلاثه شقق للسفر